[Música]
nos vamos directo hasta australia porque
el melbourne está nuestro corresponsable
de camilo montoya con las noticias del
día
camilo buen día para ustedes un saludo y
para comenzar quisiera preguntarle por
la juramentación del nuevo primer
ministro del país que sacó después de 9
años al laborismo de la oposición
hola buen día para todos ustedes si tan
solo un día y medio después de haber
sido elegido su confirmación se dio el
sábado en la noche y hoy lunes en horas
de la mañana antonio advani si se
posesionó como el primer ministro número
31 de australia lo hizo ante el
gobernador general de australia que es
el representante de la reina isabel
segunda aquí en australia acto seguido
dio su primera conferencia de prensa en
la que hizo un acto simbólico que
representó mucho para la comunidad
indígena de australia y es que detrás de
él detrás del primer ministro ordenó
instalar la bandera aborigen al lado de
la bandera australiana esto como muestra
de un apoyo y un compromiso que hizo en
campaña para proteger a estas
comunidades y luego de esto se
posesionaron otros tres ministros de
gabinete y de inmediato ante unidad
vanishing viajó a japón para reunirse
con tres aliados muy importantes de
australia con india eeuu y evidentemente
también japón para discutir temas de
seguridad sobre todo con lo que tiene
que ver con la seguridad en la región
del indo pacífico y también con lo que
tiene que ver con movimientos de china y
la situación actual que se vive con
también y un cambio radical desde tema
camilo usted es colombiano ya fue a
votar hablemos de las elecciones
colombianas que ya arrancaron en el
extranjero
bueno les cuento que hasta ahora no he
votado evidentemente empezaron las
elecciones colombianas los primeros
puestos de votación que se abrieron
fueron en nueva zelanda y australia pero
les voy a explicar por qué no he votado
resulta que en australia y nueva zelanda
hay siete puestos de votación pero solo
en tres se ha habilitado la
votación anticipada es decir desde hoy
porque la jornada es el domingo 29 de
mayo estas tres ciudades son sydney
canberra por el lado de australia y en
auckland en nueva zelanda esto es porque
estas tres ciudades tienen sede de
consulados pero esta ciudad donde estoy
que es melbourne junto con huésped y
pérez por el lado de australia y
wellington en nueva zelanda en estas
cuatro ciudades únicamente la jornada de
votación será el domingo pero unos datos
muy importantes para tener en cuenta y
es que entre australia y nueva zelanda y
16.385 colombianos habilitados para
votar se espera entonces una
participación masiva porque por el lado
de australia en las pasadas elecciones
legislativas del 13 de marzo una
participación de 4.382 colombianos
equivalente al 31 por ciento de los
habilitados y en nueva zelanda 477
votantes equivalentes al 37 por ciento
pero sin duda el domingo 29 de mayo
estaré botando aquí en melbourne